hello everybody oh my gosh that's the terms of service that's a lot of text hello hello everybody I am back oh my gosh you guys missing dragons I am back and on my first stream back I'm taking you right to a sponsor because New York was very expensive but welcome welcome we are today we are doing the cube saves us huge shout out to excel games for the sponsor for today's stream very funny story but i was actually supposed to play this game um today i think like uh yesterday but i was like you know i was like wait a minute i'm still i was like to my bad year i was like um fucked up a little bit because i'm still on my plane when i was supposed to be doing the sponsor so they're like oh can i can i can i you know push it a little bit and i was like oh wait a minute wait i'm on the plane and then i just like jokey you knew about the sponsor for for at least like two weeks now i was like okay yes but also you know i don't read the calendar
So, a huge thank you to Excel Games, to Tihi, for letting me do the sponsor today, and also for sponsoring me in general.
So, yeah, I'm really looking forward to trying, yeah, Tihi.
Okay, do it fair.
I did say I booked the tickets a super last minute to New York.
um for uh for comic-con and uh and at that time it was like hell week so I wasn't really looking at my calendar I usually do I usually do but like during that it was different it was a different time there was a different dokie during that time like I wasn't a real person I'll tell you more about that story um later on on the next stream on YouTube but but it's a lot a lot of stuff was
But yeah, so here's a shout out to XO Games for today's sponsor.
It's apparently an extraction action game.
So it's not really natural.
It's not like an extraction shooter, but extraction action game.
So melee is like the core of the combat.
And there's apparently a lot of different skills you can choose from.
So I was like looking through it.
And there's like apparently a bunch of skills you can choose.
and uh and it's about like it's in this post-apocalyptic world so we're gonna see uh we're gonna see how this goes uh i haven't played an extraction action before i played a lot of extraction shooters but not an extraction action so this is gonna be interesting because like action is apparently like um the folk core focus of the combat um and apparently like incredibly fast too So,
and there is a built-in voice control.
So, we'll see how this goes.
But, as you can check out the game.
Let me actually pin the comment.
You can check out the game right now.
Because there is early access.
So, you can try the demo right now with me as well.
And it's free.
The demo is free.
You can check out the game right now.
Yay!
uh wait is this the right i hope i pinned the right message what we're gonna find out we're gonna find out when it shows up yeah thank you for the 100 billion thank you thank you uh don't you i missed you guys too okay how do i make sure okay unpin after okay manually unpin yeah you can check out this game um all right let's go right into it let's see the cube i i hope i This lecture has late,
which may affect.
It's all right.
I can deal with that.
All right.
Oh, and there's just black.
Ooh, hello there, girl.
Oh, whoa.
I know.
Whoa.
I don't know.
Default's already pretty good.
Yo, whoa, okay, I was not, I was not expecting her.
Honestly, I'm fine with playing being defunct, yeah, like, whoa.
It's definitely not expecting this.
All right, costume.
Oh, wait.
Okay, defunct costume is already pretty good, too.
You know what?
Gotta give what God gave me.
Gotta show what God gave me.
My all-naturals.
Yeah, you got it.
You flying exactly.
I don't know.
This is already pretty good.
It's so true.
I don't know.
I mean, it look that's cool, but yeah, I show what you got Woo
You know what's it that's a what great what great return to my stream, bro Oh my god, jingle jingle.
Okay I love grab you think God gravity was invented am I right chat I think Do it again, I didn't see.
All right, did everyone see it?
Did everyone see it, cats?
Oh my God, wait, there's a bikini.
Apparently there's bikinis and cat costumes in this game.
Oh my, you know what?
I will say it is a post-apocalyptic world.
So, you know, you don't know when you're going to die.
So, like, you got to take the chance when you have it.
You know, it gotta be free.
I'm sold.
Where do I pay?
I think this is...
I think this is good.
Create nickname.
Not Doki.
They'll never know.
Yeah, life is short.
Yeah, we gotta do the tutorial.
Yes.
Oh, Jesus.
okay give me a sec um wish chat input i think oh dodge is right click okay uh the buttons what do you think i'm i'm trying to figure this out with you okay okay right click is dodge all right that's the only thing i could like remember right click is oh and these are all the the abilities and the flash petrified oh my gosh what the fuck is flash i hope it's uh okay game mode selection oh wait this not teaches you how to it's just oh my god hello the okay motion blur off let me try and make sure frame limit okay we don't don't need that we could put we could put a 200 198 close enough i'm too lazy put okay let's uh high is fine we don't need very high 198 is good enough um all right sound guy if you're here right now uh discord message me the sound stuff um okay where's the sensitivity yeah my sensitivity is way too high in this game key bindings okay we we are you are okay we okay i was
Okay, okay, people around me are listening to me, like, talking to me, I'm like, oh, she's schizophrenic, isn't she?
I was open, like, the entire time, and look at the streamer.
Okay, okay, she's like, who the fuck is she talking to?
to talk okay there we go we saved our careers uh chat is this true is this real all right let's see let's make sure we got everything now okay uh matchmaking ready is delete i don't even have that button well how am i gonna delete okay we'll put that here i'll do the backspace i'm like i will never be able to start my match all right i think that's good all right let's see oh never mind it's not we're not good oh wait controls uh wait what did i what did i do with it oh i did it click apply okay okay give me a oh shit give me a sec i didn't click i didn't even do anything i didn't click apply okay 199 that's close enough i i fixed it now i fixed everything all right oh okay there you go i think we're good okay um and then matchmaking ready there we go okay this is the only thing i applied yeah mike i i fixed the mic already that's the first thing i did okay All right.
Okay, there's my melee.
All right, we gotta...
We gotta turn down my fucking mouse sense, too.
This is still too high.
Also, this stream won't be too long.
Just so you guys know, it'll just be an hour.
Also, I did take a nap before this stream.
Because I always think, like, my body will be different.
Today will be the day my body will be okay during nap time.
It wasn't it was not Today was not that day One day it will be different.
It was just not today.
Oh my god little girl.
What are you doing here?
Wait Is she speaking in?
Wait, what language is she speak the send the news sender?
Oh, these are all.
Oh, it's a challenge.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I'll just accept it because I can.
Oh, I'm about to abandon it.
Okay, I'll just take all the quests you get.
Oh, and then the more quests you do.
Oh, my God.
She gets older.
Okay, no.
Oh, no.
It's a different person.
I was going to say, like, every quest I do, she, like, gets older or something.
I was like, oh, my God, what happened to her?
I was going to say, what happened to her?
did she go through her bell she's like i'm gonna do be a doctor now and then and then she's like you know what fuck being a doctor
okay okay okay this english i was gonna say what are you what language are you speaking i was so confused all right sound guy said uh 80 okay i'll do 80 all right where am i pressed to i don't want to start yet i don't even know where i am oh they're like are they are yeah they're like they're definitely not speaking english oh these are like she just say watashiwa i don't i don't know if they're speaking a made-up lake i can't tell if it's like um are they speaking korean yeah right it's so quiet it's so quiet i can't hear it it sounds like korean but yet like the dialogue oh yeah no it's korean yeah it is korean never mind now i can hear it yeah now i can hear it i can hear it now okay there's someone named gta okay because I was like this is definitely not English all right wait it still says delete let me fix that real quick uh wait I said that's what okay it should oh there we go PvE when you die oh yeah there's different game modes apparently too uh PvE when you die all equipped
items and Backpack items are retained when you die equip items but the items in the backpack disappear when you die all equip items Okay, we're gonna We should try I feel like I should try a normal mode Um, or solo Oh, that's scary.
I like how it's like has a skull of death Solo or I should do squat just so like I can be saved And so, my consequences, I don't have consequences for my actions if I have a team with me.
You look up?
Oh my god.
Yes, you can.
You can look up.
I like to use radio equipment collection.
What's that?
well i guess i'll never know what it is with ike oh it's just a quest all right nice okay oh this is where you store stuff so you don't have to be too scared about losing your items so you have your storage i bring overall volume to okay overall yeah oh i don't even have yeah sound yeah i don't have I don't have the uh dialogue I mean I have this overall but I hope that's good enough I don't know if there's enough people right now for squads do I have to play by myself alright if the queue takes like more than two minutes I'll queue solo and then like all you stream snipers can just I don't know not kill me I don't know I don't know just don't kill me and just drop me.
We can play as if we're in the squad.
How about that?
We'll play as if we're in the squad.
Like, what are you going to do?
Report me for teaming?
Like, oh, I think that's actually what they're going to do.
Guys, please don't report me for teaming.
Please, it's a sponsor.
it guys don't don't do that no she is that's exactly the thing they would do yes it's okay guys guys guys look jingle jing don't report me guys guys don't report me I'll give you what you want is this matching in progress I don't know that means like I guess we have to do solo okay i think we have to there we go oh wait
okay we'll do this all right we should find a game now where is this song coming from oh it's here uh i heard i remember oh i don't have any emotes oh well all right now now i should get a game right I mean if I don't we'll just do pve because like there has to be enough there doesn't have to be enough people for pve the one I'm practicing bam bam ha hang up it has to be enough right okay if we don't find anyone after uh it is like demo right now so like the game isn't actually out out yet so this is more like a demo so um I would assume that um i would assume it'll take a bit to find a game yeah is there a jump attack i i mean i'm jumping while attacking does that count oh shit oh i'm oh my gosh slash slash that's right where's your knife just got just got your stupid arms slashy slashy close enough all right if i can't find in a game after two minutes,
I'll go check the, I'll check the, uh, I'll just do PvE.
And there's just not enough people that's willing to kill each other.
There's
or we just make a full drag.
Oh my god, wait, when?
This guy's been playing for a while.
You know it.
You know, this guy that's been gaming for a while.
Wait, I don't want to buy that.
Wait, oh, is it here?
No, I think that's the...
I think he's too cloved up to be the clothing guy.
I think it was like, who sells that?
Oh, crafting shop?
Uh...
Drum.
What the fuck do I do at the drum section?
Do I play it?
Oh.
Oh, it's the throwaway stuff.
It's your trash can.
How do I get that?
okay all right all right sound team said we gotta bring it to max volume and then we'll turn the overall up volume all right that should be good it says matching in progress i wonder if that means oh my god oh my god we're getting these goods i wonder that means if i'm queuing up at the Is it him?
Does he sell that?
No, he doesn't.
Where did he get that?
I guess if I kill one of the girls, like in game, I could get it, I guess.
So like, if she dies, I can take her clothes.
I will be...
Oh my god!
Okay, I don't think she's gonna die anytime soon.
It looks like she's gaming right now.
She has like all the gaming shit.
The combo.
Yeah, she has the...
I know I'm not open mic right now.
So like I'm fine.
Is this matching in progress?
I assume...
I assume I'm getting into a game.
I hope.
It'd be awkward.
If I'm that.
Alright.
We must stay focused.
Do not let the women distract us.
Okay, what does he have?
It would be funny if he had the bikini.
Okay, no, he doesn't.
Okay, I'll be like, sir, sir, we gotta lock you up and you're selling the bikinis.
It's called The Cube Saves Us.
Oh, where am I?
Whoa.
This looks like a dangerous place now.
Oh, there's nobody here.
Wait, it says matching progress and now it disappeared.
Alright, looks like we're gonna be doing PvE.
Okay, it can't be that scary.
Alright, PvE.
It can't be that scary.
Matchmaking has started.
Alright, there we go.
We go in.
Okay, this one's instant because, like, there's no...
It's PvE, so there's no, like, threats of other people killing me.
It's spooky, man.
Alright.
Alright, we'll start.
We'll try PvE then.
I think it's just because, like, only the demo is out, so there's not enough of a player base right now to do...
To do, like, the normal mode.
Alright, there's no way a bot's gonna kill me, guys, right?
Who else here?
Hello, everybody.
What happened to everybody that's following me?
No way, right?
We should be fine, right?
We should...
I feel fine.
Okay, see, look at this.
I know all the combos.
Dodge.
That's all I need to know, right?
Let me actually look at my bindings.
Just to be sure.
Okay, control shift, look around.
Yeah.
Oh wait, combat.
Sorry, I forgot about the most important part.
Q-E-R-T.
Oh shit!
What?
Oh wait, yeah, there it is.
I forgot about this.
All right, Q.
Oh, I should... Oh, I should try... Yeah.
I mean, here's me crushing.
Oh, I could have done... I could have done squads for this.
Maybe I'll do squads after this game.
So I got a cool-ass skill.
My extraction action.
I sound... I increased the overall volume, too.
So let me know if it's better.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Is that the cube?
The cube consumes me.
Alright.
Go into the cube.
Oh, there we go.
The cube is calling for me.
Cube has been located.
It's real.
The cube.
Where am I?
Oh, this looks...
Very...
Uh...
Safe?
Transported me into a...
Oh.
Is he a bad...
Does he look like a bad person?
Oh, yeah.
No, that's a bad person.
Oh, that's right.
There we go.
Goodbye, Johnny.
What did Johnny have?
A radio receiver?
Wait, is that gun?
Oh, no, it's a machete.
Goodbye.
He's just some guy chilling.
Just had a bad trip.
He killed Johnny.
What the fuck?
Bro, Johnny was just tripping.
Oh my god, that guy has been doing too much with his free time.
That guy looks weight.
That guy is spending too much time alone.
Oh my god, Johnny's buff-ass friend.
Okay.
Oh, my god, he's punching me.
Is he hitting me?
I can't...
Yeah, he's...
is all right hello johnny johnny again hairspray used for styling hair oh there's chest i didn't even see any chest where are the chest do you guys see a chest i don't
an insufficient stamina oh there it is okay i see one sorry they were very chest shaped can corn i might need to use wait is this better oh Oh, this is better.
Alright, I'm gonna put this in the machete here.
And then, uh, how do I eat this?
Oh, shit.
Johnny, please don't come over.
I'm trying to figure out how to eat.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, we gotta grab this and then...
Om yum, yum, yum.
Om, yum.
Okay, there you go.
We're good.
Alright, we're gonna try and kill this guy.
Hope I...
I don't regret this.
Oh!
Guys, I might have...
Oh, shit.
Instant...
Wait, it broke?
Holy shit!
What kind of...
Bro, how did it already glide?
How did it already break?
Yeah, it was...
It said rare.
Okay.
It's fine.
Where did Johnny go?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Wait!
I wasn't aware!
The cube will be destroyed in six... Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
I was too busy exploring.
Oh, my God.
I have to leave the cube.
Okay, don't worry.
It's fine.
Okay, that's good.
That's good that we have a guide.
Goodbye, everyone.
Okay, now where am I?
my God there's like so okay who's this oh my God he has a knife I'm looking by oh my god oh my god oh I regret oh my god there's too many oh there's three of them die in this area oh shit okay there's way too many people here okay oh my god they do oh my god they do so much oh I break oh god oh god can i go through here oh no the cube give us and the cube take us okay maybe oh my god oh my god okay oh wait that's unfair he can also do a jump attack oh my god i'm so fucking dead this guy is this guy's a warrior this guy's a warrior i am so dead Okay.
Oh, temporary maintenance.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay, but like, I'm okay.
Okay, let's heal.
I don't think he sees me.
He will see.
Okay, we're gonna heal real quick.
We're gonna heal.
Alright.
Let's hope it opens up by then.
All right, and then I'll also yam yam yam yam
Okay, this guy took so much HP Holy oh my god literally just got here.
Oh my god, please Chill I just got here Oh my god, oh my god, there's another one I'll get the archer first I'll get the him I'll get him first before I get this guy.
Oh my god, this guy fucking sucks.
He sucks.
He actually sucks.
Please.
Oh!
Oh god.
I'll kill him first.
I have to like make sure my stamina is okay.
Okay, we got him out of the way.
Oh my god, this...
I don't like this guy.
This guy is so fucking...
He's so tanky.
Okay.
It's fine.
I still have time before the cube starts killing itself.
Alright, there you go.
I have an Oculus.
Okay, I should need more heals, though.
Three?
Kill time.
Okay.
I got...
What is that?
Detergent spray.
Guys, I do not have that much aura.
I just, I just started it.
Why do I have detergent spray?
Uh-oh, sinky.
Oh, nice.
Uh, used to, is now used for breaking other things.
It doesn't say how much, uh, when it breaks, though.
So, like, I'm a little scared about that.
Okay, I gotta get this guy.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, we gotta go.
Okay, there's a key.
cube here.
Oh!
That's fine.
We just...
We don't need to escape.
Oh, I guess that's how you, like, leave the cube.
That's alright.
We'll go to the next level.
Surely that won't fuck us up, right?
Can I go?
Now I'm here.
Yeah, I can't get over here.
Oh my god!
He's shooting me through!
Bro!
I can't even through the cube.
Bro, stop.
Okay.
The rocks can apparently get me.
Alright.
There should be a...
Alright, what does snow get me now?
Am I cold?
Am I...
Oh.
Oh, it locked up.
Okay.
We go this way.
Or we could go this way.
That doesn't really matter, right?
I don't feel safe down here.
It feels so...
I don't know.
It's awfully quiet.
It's very quiet and empty.
I do not feel safe at all.
Oh.
Oh, they're like...
Oh, my God.
No, never mind.
I feel very safe.
wait is she like calling for people to come down okay how strong is she oh shit i'm so that's scary oh my god i wasted my okay all right what does she get me she just get me binoculars that's it to be fair i don't think she has room to carry anything okay it's a hospital
escape cube here oh there's the Goliath Goliath wasn't that scary oh shit oh I didn't think he would see me so okay we'll fight outside you and me Goliath 1v1 outside here oh nice I staggered him oh my god I think I might die here actually I think I could die oh god
That's not heals.
Okay.
This might be a 07 time.
I think.
Yeah, I'm most likely gonna die here.
I think when I squat up, it'll be like so much easier.
Go upstairs.
Maybe I can find the cube up here.
I don't know.
Any escape cubes anywhere?
There's so many escape cubes from like the other room.
Yeah, there's nothing up here on the roof.
This is a very dangerous hospital.
You would think for a hospital, there'd be...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
I see it.
Wait, I wonder if I can...
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I think he could hit me.
I was going to say, I wonder if I could cheese it, but I think he could cheese it.
Okay.
Hit.
I don't think I can make the first...
hit yeah i was gonna say there's no way i can make the first hit
jesus there you go this guy's weak as hell all you got are your arms are you serious oh my god the cube will be destroyed oh i just got it the nurses oh wait the nurses guy oh my god the nurses literally blocking the cube my escape route Oh my god, and she calls people over Fucking horror
Okay, I don't lose anyone He's like, what do you say, bitch?
How is that supposed to know?
Oh my god, the axe is so slow.
Okay, turn this down and then Sound guys said turn the sound effects down.
All right, guys, we're squatting up All right, everybody.
Okay, squad time.
We might be able to get a lot of people.
We might be able to kill a lot of people in the squad.
I believe.
All right, squad up.
Solo squad up.
Let's go.
We just need two people.
Two more people.
I'm in cat.
Oh, wait.
I don't know if it's like server reliant.
I'm on Canada servers.
Oh my God.
You got a shink.
But yeah, about got an axe.
That's all you got.
You got a shink.
That doesn't mean I got a fucking axe.
Boom.
Yeah, I'm in Canada servers.
There's only one.
I don't know if it like.
I don't know.
I don't know if like squad depends on like where server you're located.
Like, this is a general lobby where it's all the servers combined.
And he has the London special.
Oh, I can't emote.
I don't got no emotes.
Oh, that's cute.
You can, like, chain...
You can have, like, a dual hair...
I like hair colors.
No, it's literally just Canada.
That's literally my server.
It was literally just Canada.
And I was like, oh, that's me.
There you go.
I guess the...
Let's start a match.
making i'm already queued up why am i queued up in normal i am i think i'm literally just fighting i think it's like four people in the squad it should be i'm literally fighting we're missing one person i think
wait is there physics when i hit it i mean we try now there isn't see she's solid we just need one person guys we need one more person to queue up and we We should be good.
We're missing one more.
One more gamer.
We have this.
I'm pretty sure Cryow Wolf is gonna be in the squad.
We have Cryow Wolf.
We have Jay.
We're literally missing it.
We're at PvE.
PvE squad.
Because I don't know if we can get a normal squad.
A normal going on.
I'm gonna try for the last time.
For the last like.
run but we literally need one guy
it's a free demo too so you guys can hop in whenever it's a free demo
we'll just jam here emperor maintenance we schedule oh like literally after i'm done thank god we will be able to we will get hit by the maintenance.
Space monk!
Cue up!
Cue up, girl!
I need one more in the squad!
Cue up!
I need one more!
I literally just need one more in my squad.
Please, whatever...
Oh, geez.
Will anyone, please, queue up!
That's it.
I'm sorry, bros.
Guys, I gotta go solo.
just say I guess I guess the world doesn't want us to squad up I'm sorry guys I gotta leave now goodbye everyone but I'm a solo gal goodbye the world said no it just wasn't it it wasn't the right time it goodbye guys okay wait I'm still here I thought it would go back Bye,
guys.
It wasn't meant to be.
I waited, though.
I gave them the time.
Try again.
Alright, I'm more geared up now.
I think I feel like they have to adjust the cube area because it's so...
It feels like such a show.
Oh, wait.
Two out of 30?
Where the fuck is the second guy?
Oh, there they are.
Who's...
Who's that over there?
Are we gonna meet up?
Oh, hey.
Hey there.
Wait, we could start teaming.
Who's gonna report us?
There's only two of us.
Unless she...
I'll report you first.
I don't say who's gonna report us.
There's just two of us.
I'll report.
If you report me, I'll report you.
I just be me anyway.
We're in the bath.
Just the two of us.
I wonder if we started the same area.
Or are they going to split us?
I feel like they'd split us off, right?
Because if there's 30 people in the lobby.
Mutually assured destruction.
Exactly.
All right.
Our sound team.
I hope the sound is all right.
What are you gonna do?
Bad me?
I'm sponsored.
I'm bad immunity.
You have nothing.
You're not sponsored.
You don't have immunity.
Alright.
Ten.
I see you on the other side.
The cube calls for me.
I feel like the actual game might be one beat me up i feel like the actual game must be longer in the queue because there's a demo you know because like i feel like in the demo we have to like go through more stuff like they want us to check out more things so i feel like in the demo it's like a lot shorter okay oh that was fast oh my item isn't jacked up that was jacked up item there
I'm strong.
I wonder if we are in the same area.
Well, there's the entrance for one of the cube.
I don't see any chests, though.
There you go.
Yeah, this is my item.
It's so strong.
Oh, I have peanut butter.
Nice.
I scroll and ate me.
What is this scroll?
An ancient scroll.
Once the seal is broken, it's content.
Yes, for some reason, everyone fears it will...
Oh shit!
Johnny?
Oh my god, so...
Oh my god, he did a combo on me.
Hey Johnny.
You know what?
Uh...
Nah, I shouldn't use it.
Alright.
I like how his name is just Johnny.
It's just so random.
Oh shit, that's...
Wait, it's just regular pants.
It's a normal pants.
I already have that.
No way he's gonna turn around, is he?
You turn around.
Oh, cool.
I got pants again.
Oh, my God.
I missed.
I missed that.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I have to let him hit first.
My charge up is too much.
But, yeah, I'll just heal now.
I have too much charge up time.
I mean, the damage is good.
I just have so much.
Charge up.
Yeah.
My turn.
Alright.
Cube has opened.
Oh, it's over here.
I haven't seen my gal J yet.
Where did she go?
She hasn't showed up.
I wonder if she's in the same arena as me.
Or she got transported so far.
Oh, you should win it, Johnny.
It's so tanky.
Ooh, a compass.
I feel like I need that.
Well, I guess I don't.
Oh, just spit.
Oh, it's broken.
Okay, that was like, I feel like I need this compass.
Oh, guess I don't.
Okay.
The door is open.
And I'm like, I should go now or...
Oh, I guess I go now.
The game- the game has spoken.
You go now.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, oh, it's back here.
Okay.
Oh, it's the same area.
It's like the same world.
Because it's- oh, I'm in like a- wait, no, actually it's different.
It's an amusement park.
Yeah, you told me to move along.
Okay, nice.
There's a box.
Box tab.
my axe has been alive for a while oh who's that is that Johnny too never got this guy's name yeah oh my god are you oh holy fuck okay okay okay definitely need heals after that holy shit that guy slapped me he gave me a sweet time to heal heal heal heal got a trip attack too what's his name long arm why is he why why does he have what does Johnny have a name his name is just long arm John Johnny is Johnny.
Oh, hey!
Hey, I see you!
Hey!
Don't worry, I got- Oh, my God, you're fucking- Don't worry, I got you.
Bam!
That's right!
You ain't gonna get my items now.
You don't need these.
There we go.
Alright, go.
Go get that guy.
Get him.
I believe in you.
Go Jay.
Jay, Jay, turn around.
Jay, you got this.
You go, Jay.
I feel like I should help.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Got some heal items.
Wait, my inventory is full.
Wait, that can happen?
Oh, it's a better.
Oh my god, it's premium band-aids in this crew.
That, guys, you know it's premium.
It's Premium Band-Aid, and it's a Korean.
That's how good this Band-Aid is, chat.
Top tier Band-Aid right there.
It's so Premium.
Wait.
Oh my god, he's wearing a cube.
I have so many items.
I should have, I should have actually...
Wait, that's just my normal band-aid.
Oh, there's a band-aid and there's standard band-aid.
I feel like I should just use my...
I feel like I should just use this.
Alright.
We gotta figure our way out of here.
Wait, actually, no.
I already figured...
Come here and follow me, Jay.
Where's Jay?
Jay, follow me.
I know where the next area is.
It's like right here.
Oh my god.
Women.
There she go.
Alright, J killer.
J.
Are you okay?
Killer.
J.
Kill this nurse.
Don't worry, I'm your only witness.
They'll never know.
There you go.
Oh my god.
She's so tanky.
Oh my god, where did he come from?
Okay, I should help Jay out.
Alright, there we go.
I was like, where the fuck did she come from?
Alright, well, Leach is nice.
Alright, let's go.
Um, I fucked up.
Okay, I fucked up.
We gotta figure.
Okay, Jay, um, um, I fucked up.
I didn't realize that, um, that- Oh my gosh, that was not the right area.
Okay, we go this way.
It's fine.
I can run past this.
Okay, Jay, we gotta run.
Jay, we're gonna get absorbed into the cube.
We have 20 seconds.
Oh, my God.
How far is this?
Wait, this is actually pretty far.
Okay, it's this way.
Follow me, Jay.
If you wanna live.
I might have fucked it up for us.
Oh, my God.
Six.
Oh, no.
Jay, goodbye, Jay.
Goodbye.
I swear.
We might have fucked up.
Jay, we like Luke Goblin a bit too much.
Oh my god!
Every Star Lord!
How do you keep getting more gear than us?
Okay, I need to put some stuff away.
Alright.
Um, I'm poor.
I gotta put my items away.
I don't even know what to do right now.
Oh wait, it has to be the crafting area, right?
Like here?
Let's try squad.
Maybe we have enough now for a squad.
Why do we do this?
Because so that I can get here instantly.
Oh, there you go.
It must be that, right?
Random crafting.
Do I have anything?
I don't.
I'm so poor.
I could sell my stuff.
I need to figure out where to sell.
Okay, this is my storage.
Storage.
Save your stuff.
Oh, wait, do I have your radio?
I have so many radios.
Surely, like, one of them.
Oh, nice!
Alright.
Uh...
I'll just put everything over there.
Fuck it.
These are, like, all my equipment, anyway.
And my pants.
If I ever lose my pants, I have this.
Alright.
and we have enough for a squad guys solo squad canada servers do we have enough now are all of you solo squad okay technically we all queue solo together we'd all be in the same lobby all right guys we have okay it's okay we have four minutes before main is i don't think we're all right i'll wait like guys okay we all queue solo and then we'll make our own squad All right,
guys, are you ready?
Okay, we'll make our squad in solos.
We have four minutes to do this.
All right.
We can do it.
We'll make our own squad.
Wait, I'm still by myself.
Team minus four minutes.
We got this team.
Team, why does it say one out of 13?
Team?
Guys, wait, what happened?
My instructors were so clear.
Guys, what happened?
I said we all go solo and we make our own squad.
Why is it say 1 out of 30?
Why did your team was gone three years ago?
They're going solos.
Guys, I said we make a squad in solo.
Where did my team go?
What if, like, I, like, queued up solo and then everyone got a game in squads?
At the same time, don't you believe the accident wasn't your fault?
I can't believe it.
Wait, they all, they got put in a different queue?
They all got together except for me and so that's not fair.
Are you kidding me?
I don't even care.
It's like you're not invited.
Toki's not invited to this party.
No.
I can't believe they did this to you.
I can't hit it.
We have two more minutes.
in the demo before it goes into maintenance.
It's alright.
Me and the all I have.
All I need is a cube.
Let me in.
Beat me up.
The cube calls for me yet again.
Me, myself, and I, the cube.
Oh my god.
It went 2 out of 30.
Oh wait.
This looks like a nice place.
Who is the second guy?
Oh it's They're in the same area.
I thought we were in, like, a castle or so.
Oh, my God.
I'm just gonna kill him right now.
Hello, Johnny.
This night...
Oh, I'm not afraid of you, Johnny.
I literally have one minute left in here.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I need him to hit first before I do my little charge-up.
I wonder what happens to me.
Do I just get kicked out?
Like instantly.
In the middle of looting this box.
It's like maintenance time.
Oh shit, those.
Nice.
Now they won't know I committed.
Now I don't leave fingerprints.
Oh, there you go.
Right on time.
I get put into the shadow realm.
There you go.
See this one?
Canada you guys were like Canada see look it literally says Canada that's literally what it says you guys are like Canada service it literally says Canada I mean it's fun it's fun I think like definitely I think like the lot more you progress um the more you progress the more you can unlock of stuff because like it says there's like other skills you can unlock as well um so there's like blink and invisibility invisibility but it's just a demo too so there's like a lot of possibilities uh there and um it would be cool to try out a squad features too um because like i feel like i feel like if you play this game with your friends it'd be like so chaotic uh because i don't I want to know if there's team damage.
That's all I really want to know.
Um, Jay, thank you for the 500 goodies.
Thank you.
Um, but yeah, um, it's fun checking out the demo.
Um, and if you want to check it out yourself, you click, well, it's maintenance right now, but you want to check it out in an hour.
You can.
Um, you can download the game right now on Steam and click on the link pinned in chat.
But it is a very short stream for the sponsor.
But I did have a lot of fun.
Like, it's a good warm-up stream for the one in an hour.
But, yeah.
A huge thank you again to The Cube Saves Us for sponsoring today's stream.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
It's great to be back.
It's great to start.
It's great to stream again.
I'm, like, trying to remember how to stream.
So, this is a good warm-up for tonight.
but yeah for those who don't know i will be doing another stream on youtube um and it's just me doing a recap of my new york trip uh and comic con and everything so yeah please feel free to check me out over there on youtube for those who don't know me my name is dokeybird i usually stream over on youtube uh but today is a sponsored stream so i'm here right now you'll know whenever i stream on twitch please feel free to check me out on twitter um i usually tweet out whenever i But yes,
thank you, everybody, for all the support, for all the follows, the bitties, the subscriptions.
I want to support me via other means.
I do have merch right now available, so check out my merch and everything.
But I guess that's everything.
I'll be live again in an hour on YouTube, so just go just like, I don't know, segue back over there.
As always, everybody, say hi, enjoy the pause check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and you stay up for me, stay up for a little longer.
So I'll be doing my back stream over there in an hour But yeah, I believe do be if you're seeing do be streaming right now So I'll go raid her I actually saw her 2d model like in person We talked like you know because we were hanging out So I already got an early access to that before you guys did I also you know saw her in person too so yeah I got backstage early access hey guys check I'll see you guys soon everyone bye guys